Baywatch is the biggest baddest movie of
the year whoa what are you wearing
freedom that's desecration it's
ridiculously fun we need to check it out
village of Glee silly rough dick
absolute must watch until area four star
watch I don't mean to interrupt but
every one of the beasts is talking about
you guys thank you
well I just wanted to invite all of you
to the Huntley but I know that the
club's kind of fancy and probably not
your scene but you're standing thank you
what oh you okay yeah hey chef hey New
Kids on the Block here is from Iowa
really I asked you this a lot of oceans
in Iowa
no just ponds and lakes and hockey
pretty boys in which what happened to
that last thing we recruit we have you
die what is this light third hazing and
that Brody told the world record the
200-meter hey Brody that Brody
yes absolutely we still don't
[Music]
I never really heard a guy's sing that
song but it was really good thank you by
the way we'll be showering here we've
gone huh you just look at my boobs
I was not my intention I didn't you like
them right now now I did cuz we were
talking about testing Oh failed oh my
god okay you just like this one again
[Music]
forget the one who steals your heart or
the one Oh
who kicks your ass some bass you [ __ ] is
happening on our Beach and my balls say
we need to go over there and check it
out
good bad idea Mitch we're lifeguards my
balls day think it he's ready well my
balls are saying [ __ ] that noise
let's go handle business your balls are
bullies they watch work because we
follow rules
this gon train wreck
I'm never OD and not a single trust is
given what a bet for is in the whole
world would like if a human [ __ ] again
T which is impossible to be so cool
[Music]
there's a cop go jack off on my sheet
just remember I'm always watching know
how to defend Leon patience matters
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
man
all things together being forgot about
work hood that's a good luck pick it up
we need search for more evidence
check his paint for needle marks moment
and check his tank lift his [ __ ]
scrotum and check his tank here is a
taint man it's a taint even look get
closer oh oh mai gerd oh there's the
hole
that's just his bundle smile most of
that do not post that just a handful of
ball flat
[Music]
he turns canals into the goddamn X game
that's because we were in lifeguard
pursuit okay love it
except for there's no [ __ ] such thing
as lifeguard pursuit
[Music]
you